SESSION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND
BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AND
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA. OUR QUE
HAN BENNETT. BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BRIAN BURKE CALDERON VIDEO
CERVANTES. TEN CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY
DAVIES LARA FONG FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER. KALRA KILEY LACKEY LEE
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA. MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN A
DONALD PATTERSON PETER NORRIS
QUIRK QUICK SILVA RAMOS RIZ
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SCIARRETTO SMITH. STONE TAKING
VALLADARES YOU PUT WHAT VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT
IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER. AS
PART OF OUR. OBSERVANCE OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR DAY
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. JONES SAWYER
MISTER JONES SAWYER. AND YES MR
JONES SAWYER IS GOING TO DO FOR
THIS TO BE OKAY I FROM FINISH
LORD WE GATHER IN THIS CHAMBER
TO REMEMBER DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR A WARRIOR OF LOVE
AND TRUTH DOCTOR CAME THROUGH
HIS ACTIONS IN LIFE'S WORK HAS
SHOWN US THE ESSENCE OF
HUMANITY. STRIVING TOWARD
UNCONSTITUTIONAL UNCONDITIONAL
LOVE FOR ONE ANOTHER WORKING TO
CHANGE UNJUST LAWS AND SERVING
THOSE MOST IN NEED SERVICE TO
OTHERS WITH OR THE WHOLE ARE
PRODUCTIVE CAME MATTER PRE HE
OBTAINED FROM HIS TEACHINGS. LET
US AS YOUR BODY A PUBLIC
SERVANTS NEVER LOSE SIGHT OF OUR
DUTY TO REPRESENT AND SERVE OUR
CONSTITUENCIES AND THE GREATER
GOOD OF ALL WITH COMPASSION
EMPATHY AND A COMMITMENT TO
BETTER THE LIVES OF OUR BROTHERS
SISTERS. IT IS THE STRENGTH OF
CHARACTER TO CONTINUE TO WORK OF
DR KING BY BEING TERRIBLE HUMBLE
AND RESPECTFUL TOWARDS ALL LOWER
ACTIONS INSPIRE MANY TO SERVE
OTHERS AS THE GOOD DOCTOR KING
HAS INSPIRED MILLIONS TO PUT
ASIDE SELF INTEREST AND STRIVE
TO BE GOOD. AND GENEROUS HUMAN
AS DR KING HAS THAT IT AS STATED
THE TIME IS ALWAYS RIGHT TO DO.
WHAT IS RIGHT. A MAN. THANK YOU
MISTRUST WHERE WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS REMAIN STANDING.
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIA
BONTA. AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I ASK THIS RISE. IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO FRIDAY
SEPTEMBER TEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ASSEMBLY MEDIC SEVEN THIRTY AM
CONNABLE KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHIEF THIRTY PARKER AT
THE DESK READING HER FAVORITE A
BELLMAN READING THE RULES CALLED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE MOVED QUORUM
CALL THIS SAM QUERREY TIME
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN AM THE
SPEAKER TIME DIRECTED THE
SERGEANT ARMS CLOSE THE DOOR AND
BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
KARMAS AT TWELVE ELEVEN PM
SPEAKER PRO TEM MONICA FORM OF
THE SIMPLY PRESENT THE ROLL CALL
IS COMPLETE IN THE FOLLOWING
ANSWER TO THEIR NAMES
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAND THEN IT BERMAN BUT BIGELOW
BLOOM BERMAN. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN IS
FLAUNTS HER MOVES AND MISTER.
FLORA SECONDS. THAT THE READ OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATION SAN
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MS RANGE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKERI REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BLOOMING CARILLO TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW ACR ONE OH
NINE OF THE ONE OF THE GARCIA
FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IN ORDER THE
RESOLUTION TO THE FIRST DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE MAN WAS
MISTAKENLY REPORTED IT TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE OBSERVANCE OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR DAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE THE FILE
ITEM FIFTY ONE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF THIRD READING. MISTER BRIAN
WILL PRESENT ACR ONE SEVENTEEN
ON BEHALF OF MR HOLDEN. MISTER
BRIAN ARE YOU READY TO PROCEED
ON THIS ITEM. SPEAKING YES I AM
. THE CLERK WILL READ ACR ONE
SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTEEN BY
FAMILY MEMBERS HOLDEN AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO REVEREND DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
MISTER BRIAN YOU MAY OPEN THE
MEASURE. MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS TO PRESENT ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY ONE. ACR ONE ONE SEVEN. A
RESOLUTION HONORING THE LATE
CIVIL RIGHTS PIONEER AND ICON.
THE REVEREND. DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR. AND AFTER THE
ARRIVAL. THE SATURDAY JANUARY
FIFTEENTH DOCTOR KING WOULD HAVE
BEEN NINETY THREE YEARS OLD.
THAT IS LIFE NOT BEEN VIOLENTLY
CUT SHORT. BY AN ASSASSIN'S
BULLET. THIS MAN WAS A LEADER. A
PASTOR- FAITH AND HOPE HELPED
HIM TO RISE ABOVE WHAT SEEM LIKE
INSURMOUNTABLE STRUGGLE. HE'S
WORKING WORDS ARE OFTEN SEEN AS
PART OF OUR SHOULD PATH. BUT
THEY'RE NOT. THE PAST THAT IT HE
WITH US RIGHT NOW. MARKING OUR
NEED FOR CONSTANT AND RENEWING
COMMITMENT TO LIBERATION SELF
DETERMINATION TO PEACE TO
EQUITY. THE JUSTICE. WE PASSED
AN ETHNIC STUDIES BILL LAST YEAR
AND SO I FEEL THE NEED TO ALSO
TELL THE TRUTH. DR KING WAS NOT
LIKE. IN THIS COUNTRY. DR KING
WAS WIRE TAPPED. DR KING WAS
ARRESTED TWENTY NINE TIMES. DR
KING WAS ASSASSINATED PROVIDING
THE THING FOR THE THINGS THAT HE
BELIEVED HE HAD MORE THAN A
DRINK. HE BELIEVED THAT YOUR
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE WERE INEXTRICABLY LINKED
. ORGANIZED WORKERS HE FOUGHT
FOR UNIONS. AND IN RETURN HE WAS
BEATEN. HE WAS SMASHED HE WAS
GRABBED HE WAS THROWN IN A
BIRMINGHAM JAIL FOR FIVE DAYS
WITHOUT JUST CAUSE. AND IN THAT
JOB HE WROTE LONG ORDER EXIST
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ESTABLISHING
JUSTICE. AND WHEN THEY FAIL IN
THIS URPOSE THEY BECOME THE
DANGEROUSLY STRUCTURED DAMS TO
THE FLOW OF SOCIAL PROGRESS. DR
KING TOLD THE TRUTH. DR KING
FOUGHT FOR US ALL. NO MATTER HOW
YOU REFLECT ON HIS HISTORY
THERE'S ONE THING THAT WE DO
ALWAYS REFRESH REFLECT ON EVERY
SINGLE YEAR. AND THAT IS HIS
PURSUIT OF PEACE. TRUE PEACE.
NOTHING TO FIND TRUE PEACE IS
NOT MERELY THE ABSENCE OF
TENSION. BUT THE PRESENCE OF
JUSTICE. I THINK IT'S FITTING
THAT THIS BODY EVERY YEAR STARTS
ARE YOU'RE OFF RECOGNIZING THE
HISTORY OF DR KING. I THINK THE
GUY POINT FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
WE DO. IN THE YEAR AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE LGBT Q. CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE SEVENTEEN.
TODAY WE HONOR A GIANT IN THE
FIGHT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS HE
SPARKED A REVOLUTION AND HIS
LEGACY IS ONE OF ACTION IN THE
NAME OF JUSTICE. DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR LED A PATH
FOR MILLIONS TO FOLLOW WE HONOR
HIM FOR PEACEFUL PROTEST AND
CONTINUE TO WORK FOR EQUAL
RIGHTS AND ANTI DISCRIMINATION
AND A MORE JUST AMERICA. DR KING
INSPIRED US TO STAND TALL IN THE
FACE OF HATEFUL RHETORIC AND
CHALLENGE THOSE WHO MAY OPPOSE
THE QUALITY AT EVERY TURN. HE
TOLD TO BE BRAVE EVEN WHEN THE
GOALS MAY NOT SEEM ACHIEVABLE.
DR KING CALLED FOR AN END TO WAR
IS BEING WAGED ABROAD. AND WILL
OF WARS BEING WE ARE AT HOME
AGAINST INNOCENT PEOPLE. IN
ORDER CAN CALL FOR JUSTICE
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC. THESE
CALLS. OF SUPPORT- VEHICLE THE
WHO DID A SUPPORT FOR GUARANTEED
INCOME. DR LINK LIKE IF DR
KING'S LEGACY IS STILL FELT
TODAY AS WE INVOKE HIS NAME AND
TRY TO FULFILL HIS DREAM OF
EQUITY AND EQUALITY FOR ALL I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN SUPPORT
OF THE C. R. ONE SEVENTEEN.
FIFTY THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WARD ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AFTER DEATH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE SEVENTEEN
FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE ACR- ONE
SEVENTEEN COMMEMORATES THE WORK
OF DR MARTHA KING JUNIOR. THE
NATIONAL HOLIDAY WE CELEBRATE IN
HIS NAME. DR KING WAS A TRUE
PATRIOT HE BOUGHT FOR WHAT
AMERICA COULD BE. NOT WHAT IT IS. FAST FORWARD TO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO. AND THIS IS STILL
TRUE TODAY. IN SOME WAYS OUR
WORK HAS JUST BEGUN. DR MARK THE
KING FOUGHT FOR RACIAL JUSTICE.
BUT HE ALSO FOUGHT FOR HEALTH
ACCESS. TODAY WE HAVE A PANDEMIC
. AND THAT IS HAT THE BLACK
COMMUNITY M. BROWN COMMUNITY
HARDEST HEALTHCARE IS A JUSTICE
. ISSUE MARTIN KING JUNIOR
HOSPITAL LIES IN MY DISTRICT AND
WE CALL IT GROUND ZERO WE'RE
FIGHTING FOR NOT ONLY ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE TO MAKING SURE THAT
INDIVIDUAL WHO NEED ACCESS TO
GET THE ACCESS THAT THEY
ABSOLUTELY NEED MEMBERS TODAY.
WE HAVE AN ADJUSTED OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM WOULD BLOCK THE
BROWN COMMUNITIES IN THIS STATE
. WE HAVE INJUSTICE WHEN IT
COMES OUT THE POOR PEOPLE AROUND
HEALTHCARE. ON THIS DAY I
CHALLENGE EACH AND EVERYONE OF
US NOT TO JUST CELEBRATE DR
MARTIN THE KING. NOT JUST TWEET
ABOUT IT NOT JUST LIKE NOT JUST
POST BUT REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND REALLY CARVE OUT
YOUR NICHE YOUR STANDS FOR TRUTH
JUSTICE AND EQUALITY IN THIS
COUNTRY. I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF US TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON THE EFFORTS OF
HEALTHCARE INEQUALITY. NOT JUST
WOULD COME DOWN TO THE BUDGET
NOT JUST WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
LEGISLATION. BUT MAKING SURE
EQUITY RINGS IN THIS HALL. I
MUST CLOSE WITH MY FAVORITE
QUOTE A DOCTOR MARTHA KING. YOUR
LIFE BEGINS THE AND THE MOMENT
YOU START BEING SILENT ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT MATTER. IN THE END
WE WILL NOT REMEMBER THE WORDS
OF OUR ENEMIES BUT THE SILENCE.
OF OUR FREEDOMS. WE WILL HAVE TO
REPENT IN THIS GENERATION NOT
MERELY FOR THE BIG TORQUE WORDS
AND ACTIONS OF THE BAD PEOPLE
BUT THE APPALLING SILENCE. ALL
THE GOOD PEOPLE BECOME THE TIME
THAT SILENCE IS A FORM OF
BETRAYAL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND TODAY I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE NEWLY FORMED
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
LEGISLATIVE POCKETS. IN SUPPORT
OF ACR ONE SEVENTEEN IN TO
COMMEMORATE THE LIFE AND LEGACY
OF DR MARTIN LUTHER KING. WE
SHOULD COMMEMORATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF DR KING JUNIOR'S
LEGACY AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS MONDAY WE MUST ALWAYS
REMEMBER DR KING'S VISION AND
EXAMPLE NOT JUST ONE DAY OUT OF
THE YEAR BUT EVERY DAY OF THE
YEAR THAT WE GET UP IN THE
MORNING WE SHOULD REMEMBER AND
MODEL OURSELVES AFTER. AFTER HIS
GUIDANCE. MR KING TO JUDGE A
PERSON BY THE CONTENT OF THE
INDIVIDUAL'S CHARACTER NOT SKIN
COLOR IS SOMETHING THAT STILL
RESONATES TODAY. TO FIGHT FOR
WHAT IS JUST AND RIGHT THAT
CONTINUES TO BE WHAT WE TALK
ABOUT IN THIS CHAMBERS TODAY IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND TO
PRESERVE TO PRESERVE THAT WAS
WHAT HIS LIFE EXEMPLIFIED. DR
KING'S SPIRIT AND LYFT CREATED A
PIVOTAL MOMENT IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY A HISTORY THAT STILL IS
PLAYING OUT TODAY. IN WHICH
TRANSFORM THE LIVES OF NOT ONLY
AFRICAN AMERICANS BUT DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR PAVE
THE WAY FOR SO MANY OF US OF
COLOR IN THE COUNTRY AND IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE CONTINUE
TO LIVE OFF OF THE WORDS THAT DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING CONTINUES TO
MOVE FORWARD TODAY IN THE SAGE.
CHANGE DOES NOT ROLL IN ON THE
WHEELS OF AND THE END OF IT
ABILITY BUT COMES THROUGH
CONTINUOUS STRUGGLE CONTINUOUS
STRUGGLE THAT MANY OF OUR PEOPLE
STILL SEE TODAYTOGETHER IN
DIVERSITY. TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY PERSON OF COLOR NOT ONLY
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BUT ACROSS THE NATION CONTINUES
TO GET UP AND MOVE FORWARD. AND
TO REMEMBER THAT THE DREAM THE
MARTIN LUTHER KING HAD AND STILL
PLAYS OUT TODAY IS FOR ALL OF US
IN FOR THE VOICES OF THOSE THAT
ARE OUT THERE THOSE OF THAT HAVE
BEEN A PRESS. THAT THAT VOICE
STAND STRONG TOGETHER IN UNITY
IN UNITY TO MOVE FORWARD TO COME
AGAINST THOSE AREAS THOSE AREAS
THAT NOW PLAGUES SO MANY PEOPLE
THE COLONIZATION. SLAVERY WE
SHARE THAT WITH IN THE NEW
AMERICAN COMMUNITY WE STAND SIDE
BY SIDE WITH OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS TO RECOGNIZE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE DREAM THAT
MARTIN LUTHER KING HAD IS NOT
JUST FOR WHAT PEOPLE IS FOR ALL
PEOPLE. ALL PEOPLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION WE
STAND SIDE BY SIDE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT DREAM MOVES FORWARD IN
THE VOICES OF ALL INCLUDING THE
A DIGIT AS PEOPLE STEPS TOGETHER
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD. AND DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING'S VISION THE MODEL
OURSELVES AFTER HIM AND HIS
PERSEVERANCE THAT HE MOVED OVER
AND FORWARD FOR ALL OF US I
THANK YOU AND I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS ACA. THANK YOU
RESTAURANTS. MR GABRIEL. YOUR
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS TO HONOR THE
REMARKABLE LIFE AND LEGACY OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR. WANT
TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
PASADENA CALLING FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR BRING FOR THIS
RESOLUTION. JEWISH CAUCUS IS
PROUD TO STAND WITH THE BLACK
CAUCUS AND WITH CALIFORNIANS OF
ALL BACKGROUNDS IN RECOGNIZING
DR KING. AS ONE OF THE GREATEST
AMERICANS OF ANY GENERATION
THERE'S A TRUE SYMBOL OF JUSTICE
AND EQUALITY FOR ALL. AND AS WE
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO WORK
TOWARDS TRUE RACIAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE. IT IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER THAT WE REMEMBER THE
LEGACY IN LIFE OF DR KING. HE
WILL ALWAYS OCCUPY A SPECIAL
PLACE IN THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF
AMERICAN JEWS. FOR MANY IN OUR
COMMUNITY HE WAS THE LIVING
EMBODIMENT OF THE QUEST FOR
FREEDOM. FOR HUMAN DIGNITY AND
JUSTICE BUT ARE THE CENTRAL
FOCUS OF THE JEWISH TRADITION.
THERE ARE FEW IMAGES THAT
INSPIRE AS MUCH PRIDE AND
EMOTION IN OUR COMMUNITY AS THE
ICONIC PHOTOGRAPH. OF RABBI
ABRAHAM JOSHUA HESCHEL THE MOST
REVERED AMERICAN RABBI OF ANY
GENERATION. MARCHING ARM IN ARM
WITH DR KING ACROSS THE EDMUND
PETTUS BRIDGE IN MARCH OF
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE. WHAT WHAT
HE SAID AFTERWARDS WITH THE
RABBI SAID AFTERWARDS IN WORDS
THAT RECORDED BY PRESENT OBAMA
HALF A CENTURY LATER LATER. HE
SAID THAT WHEN HE WAS MARCHING
WITH DR KING HE FELT AS IF HIS
LEGS WERE PRANK. DR KING AS AS
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM THE NATIVE
AMERICAN CAUCUS MENTION WAS AN
INCREDIBLE ALLY TO OTHER
COMMUNITIES. CERTAINLY TRUE THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY HE SPOKE OUT
POWERFULLY. ABOUT OUR STRUGGLES
ABOUT ANTI SEMITISM. ABOUT
PERSECUTED JEWS IN THE SOVIET
UNION. IT WAS AN INCREDIBLE
MORAL VOICE FOR ALL PEOPLE
FACING OPPRESSION. I THOUGHT IS
INTERESTING ARE CALLING FROM LOS
ANGELES MENTIONED THAT HE IS A-
IN ETHICAL GUIDE POST THAT IT IS
MOST APPROPRIATE THAT WE BEGIN
OUR LEGISLATIVE SESSION
REFLECTING. ON THE WORK OF DR
KING. AND IT REMINDED ME
ACTUALLY OF THE JEWISH HIGH
SCHOOL IN MY DISTRICT DE TOLEDO
HIGH SCHOOL. WHEN YOU WALK INTO
THAT HIGH SCHOOL THE FIRST THING
YOU WILL SEE IN THE ENTRYWAY IS
AN ENORMOUS MURAL UP ON THE
FRONT ENTRANCE. OF RABBI RABBI
ABRAHAM HOW JOSHUA HESCHEL DR
KING. AND THAT IS NOT AN ACTION
IS VERY INTENTIONALLY PLACE
THERE TO TEACH THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE LESSEN. ABOUT WHO WE
VENERATE ABOUT WHO THEY SHOULD
SEEK TO EMULATE ABOUT WHAT THEY
SHOULD ASPIRE TO BE. THEY SHOULD
LOOK AT DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
AND RABBI HESCHEL AND UNDERSTAND
THAT THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
FOUGHT FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SEEK TO EMULATE. AND SO THIS
WEEKEND JEWISH COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
GONNA HOLD SPECIAL SERVICES AN
HONOR DR KING OFTEN INTERFACE
SERVICES WERE WE PARTNER WITH
OTHER COMMUNITIES. WE'RE GONNA
THINK ABOUT HIS UNFINISHED
STRUGGLE FOR JUSTICE. WE'RE
GOING TO CELEBRATE SAID HOW MUCH
SHE ACCOMPLISHED IN A SHORT TIME
pREFLECT HONESTLY ABOUT HOW MUCH
WORK IS LEFT TO BE DONE TO
ALTERNATELY FULFILL HIS VISION.
AND I THINK THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT WAY THAT WE CAN HONOR
THAT WORK IS PEOPLE OF ALL
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS OF COLORS
OF FAITH TRADITIONS OF KRIETZ
COMING TOGETHER. AND CONTINUING
HIS WORK FOR ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
AND RACIAL JUSTICE WITHOUT ON
BEHALF OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
BEHALF OF ACR ONE SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL MISTER
MURATSUCHI. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I RISE IN.
ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER LET'S THAT
OF CAUCUS. TO SUPPORT. THEIR
COMMEMORATION OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING AND HIS LEGACY WITH
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT. AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE MAY WONDER WHAT
DID DR KING MEAN FOR ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
. AND I THINK IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING. THAT ALL OF US INCLUDING
ASIAN AMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS THAT WE WOULD NOT HAVE
THE PRIVILEGES TO BE ABLE TO
LIVE IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT
WE LEVIN AND GO TO THE SCHOOLS
THAT WE GO TO AND WORK AND WORK
PLACES THAT WE WORK AND- BUT FOR
. THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
THAT IS DR KING'S LEGACY. AND
YET TOO MANY ASIAN AMERICANS. DO
NOT KNOW THIS HISTORY THAT WE
ENJOY THE PRIVILEGES. AND
BENEFITS OF PEOPLE THAT FOUGHT
FOR AND DIED FOR THESE RIGHTS
THAT WE TAKE FOR GRANTED. AND SO
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. IT IS OUR
TIME AS WAS TALKED ABOUT IN THE
LAST LED BLACK CAUCUS BREAKFAST
. CEREMONY ON ON WEDNESDAY. IT
IS OUR TIME TO NOW STEP UP AND
FIGHT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS. AND AS
MANY INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF SAID. THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE OF OUR TIME
NOW. IS TO FIGHT FOR VOTING
RIGHTS. AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL THAT DR KING IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT ACCOMPLISHED IN
TERMS OF ENSURING. THE RIGHT TO
VOTE FOR ALL AMERICANS IS NOT A
ROAD ID. BYE EFFORTS TO
UNDERMINE THE CREDIBILITY AND
ABILITY OF ELECTIONS. AND WITH
THE EFFORTS TAKEN ABOUT TAKING
PLACE IN STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO VOTE. AND SO ON
BEHALF OF ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LESS THAN CAUCUS. I
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CARSON. AND REMINDING ALL
OF US OF DR KING'S WORDS. THAT
ALL IT TAKES. FOR EVIL TO
PREVAIL. AND FOR US TO LOSE THE
RIGHTS THAT PEOPLE HAVE FOUGHT
FOR AND DIED FOR. IS FOR GOOD
PEOPLE TO REMAIN SILENT. I
REMIND ALL OF US THE IMPORTANCE
. NOW MORE THAN EVER TO STAND UP
. FOR CIVIL RIGHTS FOR OUR
VOTING RIGHTS FOR ALL AMERICANS
. THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI DR
WEBER. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION ACR. ONE
SEVENTEEN. DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR ONCE SAID. WE ARE NOT
MAKERS OF HISTORY. WE ARE MADE
BY HISTORY. SO I ASK US TODAY TO
REFLECT ON THOSE WORDS. ABOUT
WHAT TYPE OF PERSON HISTORY HAS
CREATED IN YOU. AS WE NOW
WITNESS THE MULTIPLE ATTEMPTS TO
DEMOLISH OUR DEMOCRACY WE SIT IN
SILENCE OUR HISTORY WORLD IN YOU
THE DESIRE TO FIGHT BACK BECAUSE
OF THE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN OUR
HISTORY WHO HAVE FOUGHT AND DIED
TO KEEP DEMOCRACY ALIVE. AS WE
NOW SEE THE WHEELS OF TIME BEING
TURNED BACKWARDS. AS A NEW WAVE
OF JIM CROW LAWS SWEEP OF OUR
NATION. WHEN YOU TURN YOUR HEAD
THE OTHER WAY. OR HAS HISTORY
GIVING YOU THE COURAGE TO NOT
ALLOW US TO RETURN TO DARKER
DAYS IN OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY.
AS WE SEE MANY OF US STILL
FIGHTING FOR FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS.
W DO CLOSE YOUR EYES WE'RE HAS
HISTORY INSTILLED IN YOU THE
RESOLUTION TO STAND FOR WHAT IS
CHEST. AS WE SEE PEOPLE SO
CRAVING FOR POWER THAT THEY WILL
DO AND SAY ANYTHING EVEN IF IT'S
A LIE. DO YOU SAY AND DO
NOTHING. OR DO YOU SPEAK UP EVEN
IF IT'S AGAINST PEOPLE IN YOUR
OWN CIRCLE. M. OKAY ALSO SAID I
AM NOT INTERESTED IN POWER FOR
POWER'S SAKE BUT I'M INTERESTED
IN POWER THAT IS MORAL THAT IS
RIGHT THAT IS GOOD. SO I ASK US
TO NOT JUST REMEMBER HIS LIFE OR
HIS ICONIC I HAVE A DREAM
SPEECH. BUT ALSO REMEMBER HIS
FIGHT. AND HIS SACRIFICE AND USE
THAT TO HELP SHAPE WHO WE ARE
HOW WE FIGHT AND HOW WE SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU. P. R. ONE
TEAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR
WEBER MR COOLEY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I AM
PLEASED TO RISE TODAY I MIGHT
SAY ICE ARISES IS SURE TO SIMPLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON FOSTER CARE
. BUT ACTUALLY I RISE BECAUSE I
HAVE A GRANDDAUGHTER ANNA WHO'S
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN HERITAGE. I
HAVE A GRANDSON BEN WHO IS OF
ASIAN HERITAGE. MAKES ME REFLECT
UPON. THIS HISTORIC FIGURE DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING ALL THE WORK
HE DID. INCONTESTABLE HE BENT
THE CURVE OF HISTORY. AND YET I
ALSO REFLECT UPON IT IS RIGHT
THAT WE CELEBRATE HIM IN THIS
CHAMBER. BECAUSE EACH ONE OF US.
HAS RESPONSIBILITY AN OFFICE
FROM WHICH WE TOO CAN WORK TO
BEND THE CURVE OF HISTORY. SO IT
IS RIGHT THAT WE LOOK TO HIM FOR
INSPIRATION. AND I WANT TO
AFFIRM THAT THIS THIS IS THE
INHERENT NATURE OF OUR WORK. AND
PARDON ME FOR THIS REMINDER.
THIS WEEK IN HONG KONG. IT IS
REPORTED THAT THE NEW HONG KONG
LEGISLATURE WAS SEATED. AND IT
IS THE FIRST LEGISLATURE SEATED
UNDER THE NEW BEIJING
REQUIREMENT. THAT ALL LAWMAKERS
BE PATRIOTS. A LETTER SAY BODY
COMPRISED OF ONE OUTLOOK ONE
VIEW IS NOT A LUXURY BODY. I
THINK WHAT DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
STAND FOR IS THE EMBODIMENT. OF
WHAT OUGHT TO BE THE SPIRIT OF
INQUIRY OF THIS BODY THE SPIRIT
OF ADVOCACY OF THIS BODY. THAT
WE ARE ALWAYS IN THE FACE OF THE
NEEDS THAT WE SEE. OPEN TO SEE
AN AND ARTICULATED WHAT MIGHT
SEEM TO SOME AS WILD IDEAS. AND
BECAUSE ONCE THOSE GET PUSHED
OUT. THEN WE START TO HEAR THE
PEOPLE WHO SEE THE OBSTACLES THE
CRITICISMS WE MIGHT SEE
CRITICISMS BUT WE WORKED IN
OCTOBER'S OFF. TO TRY TO
IMPLEMENT A VISION OF CHANGE
AFFECTING HISTORY. AND AS SOON
AS YOU START GOING DOWN THAT
TRAIL OF BEING OPEN TO WILD
IDEAS AS DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
ARTICULATED AND START DEALING
WITH WHAT MIGHT BE CRITICISMS
THEN YOU START. WORKING OUT HOW
YOU CAN ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT A
WILD IDEA YOU START DE RISKING
IT. AND THEN AND ALL OF THIS WE
NEED TO HAVE THE ELEMENT OF
TIME. SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THIS
IS A DAY ABOUT DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING BUT I THINK HE ACTUALLY.
PERSONIFIES A- IMPACT ON HISTORY
WHICH IS ACTUALLY OUR RIGHTS
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION EACH ONE
OF US TO BE THIS TYPE OF MEMBER
THAT GRAPPLES WITH THE PRESIDENT
WITH THE VISION OF THE FUTURE
OPEN WILD IDEAS ABLE TALK ABOUT
THE PROS AND CONS FIX IT TO
AVOID ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES AND
ALWAYS DOING THIS WHOLE TIME IS
OUR FRIEND AND NOT OUR- MASTER.
DRIVING US- MINDLESSLY FORWARD
SO I THINK. IT IS SO IMPORTANT
TO REFLECT UPON THE GREATNESS
AND THE SINGULARITY. OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING IN THE IMPACT
HE HAD. AND I JUST WANT TO SAY.
ON BEHALF OF MY GRAND KIDS BUT
ON BEHALF OF EACH ONE OF US I
WOULD JUST SAY WE ALL WANT TO
OWN IT. BECAUSE WE ARE UNIQUE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THIS OFFICE WE
HOLD. AND THE MANTLE A BIT IN
THE FUTURE WHICH- WHICH DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING CARRIED IS
DOUBLE STORED UPON US. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA YOU'RE NOW
RECOGNIZED AFTER DEATH. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THAT DO NOT
PRACTICE AND WOMEN'S PURPOSE IN
OBSERVANCE OF REVEREND DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR DAY AS WE
CELEBRATE DR KING'S LIFE AND
LEGACY LET US REFLECT ON HOW WE
CONTINUE HIS JOURNEY ON THE
MORAL ARC TOWARDS JUSTICE
BECAUSE IN THIS MOMENT OUR
SOCIETY LOOKS MORE LIKE THE
COUNTRY THEN AND NOT THE
RACIALLY AND ECONOMICALLY JUST
SOCIETY HE DREAMED FOR US. I WAS
RAISED IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT WITH FORTY FOUR PARENTS
WERE ACTIVE MEMBERS OF THE YOUNG
LORDS PARTY IN NEW YORK STANDING
SIDE BY SIDE THE BLACK PANTHERS
FROM CALIFORNIA TO NEW YORK CITY
THE FAR OUTSIDE OF THE HALLS OF
POWER FOR THE SEAT AT A TABLE
LIKE THE ONE HI AND WE NOW HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE TO SIT IN TODAY.
THEY OFTEN SHARED WITH ME THAT
HALF OF LEADERSHIP IS SHOWING
UP. BUT FOR LEADERSHIP IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU SHOW UP. WITH
THE KNOWLEDGE OF HOW YOU SHOW
UP. I ASK YOU COLLEAGUES TODAY
TO HOLD IN YOUR MIND'S EYE. ONE
OF THE MOST ICONIC MOMENTS
EXPRESSING ALLYSHIP IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT. AND PRESS WE
CAN DROP HAN AND GAZE UPON. THAT
MOMENT IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE IN
SELMA ALABAMA. CROSSING OVER THE
EDMUND PETTUS BRIDGE. THE EXPAND
OUT INTO THE CROWD AROUND OUR
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING.
RECOGNIZE THE PEOPLE BEFORE US
LINKING ARMS TOGETHER.
REGARDLESS OF ETHNICITY RACE
SENDER IDENTITY OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR FAITH THEY SET
TOGETHER AND I SUBMIT TO YOU
COLLEAGUES AT THAT CROWD WAS
ABLE TO BUT ULTIMATELY CROSS
THAT BRIDGE AND SECURE THE
PROMISE OF AN INTEGRATED SOCIETY
AND I JUST SOCIETY BECAUSE OUR
BLACK AND BROWN BROTHERS AND
SISTERS DEMANDED THAT INTENTION.
OF OUR ALLIES. I WOULD LOVE FOR
YOU IF YOU ARE ABLE TO NOW.
STAND UP. COLLEAGUES I ASK YOU
TO DO THIS BECAUSE WE CAN'T LINK
ARMS IN THIS MOMENT WE CAN'T
HOLD EACH OTHER BECAUSE OF THIS
PANDEMIC BUT AS A REMINDER OF
THAT MOMENTS IN AT THE ADMIN G.
PETTUS BRIDGE ASK YOU TO RISE.
DR KING SAID ONCE EVERYBODY CAN
BE GREAT BECAUSE ANYBODY CAN
SERVE. YOU ONLY NEED A HEART
FULL OF GRACE A SOUL GENERATED
WITH THE LAB. I ASK YOU DOWN IN
YOUR HEART I. THE THINK ON HOW
WE CAN COLLECTIVELY BE ALLIES
THE DOCTOR KING EXPECTED US TO
BE. AND I ASK YOU TO CONSIDER IN
THIS MOMENT NOW. AS WE TRY TO
UNRAVEL THE VESTIGES OF SLAVERY
FROM THE FABRIC OF THE TRUTH YET
OFTEN TESTED DEMOCRACY THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW. I ASK YOU TO
HOLD IT IN YOUR HEARTS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IN THE SESSION.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR JOINING
AND SITTING WITH ME IN THIS
MOMENT OF STILLNESS THAT WE
OFTEN NEED. AS LEADERS SO THAT
WE CAN LEAD WITH POWER IN OUR
PRIVILEGE. WE STAND ON THIS
CARPET. OF GREEN. THEY STOOD ON
CEMENT. WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
BRIDGE ACROSS. OUR POWER IN OUR
PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE TO REACH
THOSE WHO ARE IN NEED IN THIS
FINE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
DIVERSITY IN CALIFORNIA UNLOCKS
THE POWER WE ALWAYS HEALTH. AND
WHEN WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY AND
THROW OFF THE CHAINS OF
DIVISION. THAT IS WHEN WE CAN BE
SPOOLIE STAND IN OUR LEADERSHIP.
I THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AND
RESPECTFUL WE ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA
IS THERE ANY FURTHER QUESTION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE. SEEING
AND HEARING NINE MISTER BRYANT
YOU MAY NOW CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MY BROTHER'S
ASSISTANT LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS WITHIN THE INDIGENOUS
CAUCUS ASIAN AMERICAN CAUCUS IN
THE JEWISH. BROTHERS AND SISTERS
AND ALL STUDENTS ARE THERE ANY I
ASKED THE WILL BE OPEN FOR A
COUPLE. ALL DEBATE HAVE SEIZED
WILL MOVE. TO A VOTE ON THE
MEASURE. MISTER BRIAN WOULD YOU
LIKE THE FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS YES. MISTER BRYAN
HAVE ASSET THE ROLE BE OPENED SO
MEMBERS MAY ADD AT HONEST
COLLECTORS THE CLERK WILL NOW
OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS ON
ACR ONE SEVENTEEN. THE CLERK
WILL NOW CLOSE THE ROLE. ABOUT
YOUR FEDERAL. WHEN I CLOSE THE
ROLE. THERE ARE SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ADDED. WE WILL NOW TAKE
A VOTE ON THE MEASURE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE CAN NOW TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON ACR ONE SEVENTEEN
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED
SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
THANK YOU PERSISTING IN THE
COMMEMORATION OF ONE OF OUR
NATION'S MOST IMPORTANT FIGURES
THIS CONCLUDES THE ASSEMBLY'S
OBSERVANCE OF DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING S. BIRTHDAY THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO BE ON
THE DAY FILE. ASSEMBLY SECOND.
OPERATOR ASSEMBLY WILL NINE
THIRTIETH WITH A SOME SIX AND
SIX WITH MAMMOTH AND A SOME BILL
FORTY TEN WITH MY- ALL BILLS
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND- TO.
ADOPTED. GOVERNOR'S VETOES FILE
ITEMS FOUR THROUGH FORTY SIX
ITEM SHALL BE CONTINUED
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS ON
RECONSIDERATION. SHELBY
CONTINUED. WE ARE AT THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
FIVE FORTY EIGHT THROUGH FIFTY
PASS AND RETAIN. WE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE. WE ARE
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO THIS IS AB
TWELVE TWELVE BY DOCTOR WOULD.
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
TWELVE BY SIMPLY MEMBERS
WOULDN'T OTHER THAN ACTUALLY THE
TRIBAL GAMING. DR WHEN YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWELVE TWELVE IS A
BILL TO RATIFY GAMING COMPACTS
FOR THREE TRIBES IN MY DISTRICT.
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
REMOVES THE DAY COMPACTS WERE
EXECUTED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
BECAUSE THE CONTACTS NEED TO BE
REVISED. REVISION OF THE
CONTACTS IS NEEDED DUE TO RECENT
FEDERAL ACTION DISAPPROVING SOME
CONS CONTACTS THEY WERE RATIFIED
LAST YEAR. THE FEDERAL
DISAPPROVAL WAS OVER TECHNICAL
ISSUES THAT ARE CURRENTLY BEING
ADDRESSED ONCE THE CONTACTS HAVE
BEEN APPROPRIATELY REVISED IN
THE UPSET UPDATED X. DAY. B.
TWELVE TWELVE IN THE SENATE AND
WILL RETURN TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR
CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION. ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRABLE. WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY ONE TWO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM FIFTY
THREE AB FOURTEEN NINETY ONE
MCCARTY CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN NINETY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AN
ACT RELATING TO DEALT EDUCATION
MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS MEASURE WILL ENSURE
THAT MORE DOLLARS THAT ARE FUN
IN OUR STATE BUDGET THROUGH
ADULT FOR ADULT EDUCATION.
FOCUSED ON EXPANDING ADULT
EDUCATION ESL PROGRAMS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TOO OFTEN DISTRICTS
HAVE A REASONABLE RESERVE
SOMETIMES OF TALLYING MORE THAN
25% OF THEIR ALLOCATION. THIS
BILL THROUGH- WORKING WITH-
EDUCATION COMMITTEE STAKEHOLDERS
SETS A REASONABLE CAP OF 15% OUR
RESERVES FOR YEAR TO YEAR
CARRYOVER FUNDS ENSURING THAT
MORE OF THESE SCARCE RESOURCES
ARE UTILIZED IN OUR COMMUNITIES
FOR OUR ADULT LEARNERS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER KERN. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION FOR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. THAT OF A-
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS ADAMANT. CLICK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SIXTY NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS
IS FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR AB. FIVE
FORTY SEVEN FOUR FOUR THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AN ACT
RELATING TO VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND STALKING. MR
MCCARTY MEGAN OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS MEASURE WILL
EXPAND PROTECTIONS FOR SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
UNFORTUNATELY RATES OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ARE NOT DECREASING
CALIFORNIA MORE THAN ONE IN
THREE WOMEN IN OUR STATE HAVE
EXPERIENCED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
INCLUDING MANY. IN OUR OWN
FAMILIES- THIS MEASURE THAT HELP
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BY ENSURING
THAT THEY KNOW THE ADDRESS AND
THEY'RE NOTIFIED OF THEIR
PERPETRATORS ADDRESS WHEN
RELEASED UPON PROBATION AT TO
OFFING- STOCKING ANOTHER AND-
YOU KNOW INCIDENTS- PUT
INDIVIDUALS AT RISK WHEN
INDIVIDUALS ARE PLACED ON
PROBATION AFTER DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SENTENCE. AT THIS-
MEASURE OF SUPPORT SUPPORT. ASK
YOUR RIVAL THIS AFTERNOON THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER COURTESY
NO DISCUSSION. ADAM CLARKE
LOEFFLER ALL. THE CEREMONY
MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DECIDABLE. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AND I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES I HAVE A FIFTY
FIVE THROUGH FIFTY NINE PASS TO
RETAIN. SENATE THIRD READING.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY. SB.
FIVE OH FOUR ACCORDING. SENATE
BILL FIVE A FOUR WITH A MEMBERS
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN. THIS
IS FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. MISTER BRYANT TWENTY MINUTES
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
. SB FALL FOR THE BIPARTISAN
VOTER REGISTRATION MEASURE
SPONSORED BY OUR STATE CLERKS
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS THERE ARE
TWO AMENDMENTS THE FIRST
CLARIFIES THE SECRETARY OF STATE
CAN ISSUE CONSISTENT STATEWIDE
REGULATIONS FOR THESE NEW
PROCEDURES THE SECOND IS AN
URGENCY CLAUSE. SO THAT EVERYONE
CAN REGISTER TO VOTE IN ADVANCE
OF THE UPCOMING PRIMARY
ELECTION. IS PRO DEMOCRACY
LEGISLATION THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION IN THE AUTHOR'S WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE AND ARE COUNTY
CLERK'S I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRIME WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES
HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
. ALSO THE PRINTER BACK ON FILE
. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CLERK WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
. DECEMBER FOURTEEN WITH THE
MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS. MR RIVAS ON THESE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND- THESE AMENDMENTS TO
SENATE BILL FOR EIGHTEEN BY
CENTER LAYERED THESE AMENDMENTS-
WILL CHANGE THIS BILL INTO
LEGISLATION ESTABLISHING THE NEW
PAPAROA VALLEY HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT THE COUNTIES OF SANTA
CRUZ AND MONTEREY. FOR THE
PURPOSES OF TAKING OWNERSHIP OF
THE WATSONVILLE THE COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL SPECIFICALLY THESE
AMENDMENTS. WILL LAY OUT THE
BOUNDARIES OF THIS NEW HEALTH
CARE DISTRICT WILL MAKE CLEAR
THAT THE NEW DISTRICT WILL BE
SUBJECT TO THE OVERSIGHT OF
LOCAL LAST GOES. AND I- THE
PROPOSES TO DO THAT THAT THAT
DIRECT THE INITIAL BOARD OF
DIRECTORS TO ESTABLISH ZONES FOR
THE EVENTUAL ELECTION OF FUTURE-
REPRESENTATIVES AMONG OTHER- THE
PROVISIONS RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU MISTER RIVERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. HI POSAY
NAME. THE I. SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT OF PRINT. AND
BACK ON FILE. AND MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY ROLE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO. I AM
REFERRING ADAM SIXTY ONE SB FOUR
EIGHTEEN TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE. FILE ITEMS SIXTY TWO
AND SIXTY THREE. ASCERTAIN.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A CONSECUTIVE.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE SECOND A
CONTENT CALENDAR THERE ARE
CALENDAR. BEFORE WE THOUGH WE
WILL FIRST TAKE UP FILE ITEM
SIXTY FIVE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADDIG CO AUTHORS. CLERK WILL
READ THE RESOLUTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE ELEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CHOI
ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY. THE CLERK WILL NOW
OVER THE ROLE TO ALLOW ANY
MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR
OF THE RESOLUTION. FOR CALL
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. IF
YOU WISH TO ADD YOUR NAME AS A
CO AUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTION I
CONSENT PLEASE VOTE NOW. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
. ON CONSENT. CLARK WELL CLOSER
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ADDED. WE WOULD TO VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ANY
MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING
HEARING NONE CLERK WILL READ THE
SECOND A CONTENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE ELEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBERS
JOIN OTHERS RELATED TO KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY. BURKE WILL OPEN
THE ROLE IN THE CONSENT CALENDAR
. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AREN'T ABOUT THIS
IS CONSENT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CLERK WILL. CLOSE A
ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY NINE
NO ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY FOUR HIGHS
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO. MEMBERS OF
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. MEMBERS I
WOULD. BEFORE WE MOVED TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY I WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE
BIRTHDAYS TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER THAT IS TODAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY SIR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI A JANUARY FIFTEENTH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ISAAC BRYAN.
JANUARY SIXTEENTH HE'LL BE
TURNING THIRTY. HAPPY BIRTHDAY
SIR. MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME. WE ARE
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
FOR MANY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. WE'RE AT A GERMAN TO
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS. WE'RE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS COMING MONDAY WOULD
HAVE BEEN BETTY WHITE'S ONE
HUNDREDTH BIRTHDAY. AND SO IT IS
WITH A DEEP SENSE OF
APPRECIATION FOR A LONG LIFE
WELL LIVED THEN I RISE TO
ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF MS BETTY
WHITE AND EIGHTY FIFTY
CONSTITUENTS HOLLYWOOD LEGEND
AND CULTURAL ICON WHO PASSED
AWAY ON NEW YEAR'S EVE AFTER AN
IMPRESSIVE LIFE AND CAREER. THAT
SPANNED WELL OVER SEVENTY YEARS
. BETTE MARION WHITE WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO IN ILLINOIS
TO A HOMEMAKER AND A LIGHTING
COMPANY EXECUTIVE. SHE WAS AN
ONLY CHILD AND HER FAMILY MOVED
TO ALL HAMBRE BEFORE HER FIRST
BIRTHDAY. UPON GRADUATING FROM
BEVERLY HILLS HIGH SCHOOL SHE
BEGAN MODELING AND ACTING TAKING
A BRIEF BREAK TO VOLUNTEER FOR
THE AMERICAN WOMEN'S VOLUNTARY
SERVICES IN WORLD WAR TWO. WHERE
HER ASSIGNMENTS INCLUDED DRIVING
A P. X. TRUCK WITH MILITARY
SUPPLIES. A TELEVISION PIONEER
SHE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST WOMEN
TO HOLD POSITIONS BOTH IN FRONT
OF AND BEHIND THE CAMERA. HE'S
RECOGNIZED AS THE FIRST WOMAN TO
PRODUCE A SITCOM LIFE WITH
ELIZABETH FOR WHICH SHE EARNED
HER VERY FIRST EMMY. AND THE
HONORARY TITLE MAYOR OF
HOLLYWOOD. WHAT THE NEXT SEVERAL
DECADES BETTY WHITE'S CAREER
MOVED ALONG IN A WAY THAT PROVED
THAT SHE WAS BOTH LOVABLE AND
VERSATILE. HE WAS A REGULAR ON
TELEVISION SHOWS SUCH AS THE
MARY TYLER MOORE SHOW. AND
HOSTED NUMEROUS GAME SHOWS WHERE
SHE MET HER HUSBAND ALLEN LUDDEN
THEY WERE MARRIED IN NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE. BETTY WHITE WENT ON
TO STAR IN THE HIT TV SHOWS SUCH
AS THE GOLDEN GIRLS AND HOT IN
CLEVELAND AND RETURN TO THE BIG
SCREEN IN ROMANTIC COMEDIES SUCH
AS THE PROPOSAL ALONGSIDE SANDRA
BULLOCK AND RYAN REYNOLDS. WHEN
SHE HOSTED NBC'S SATURDAY NIGHT
LIVE IN TWENTY TEN IT WAS ONE OF
THE HIGHEST RATED EPISODES IN
THE SHOW'S HISTORY. AND SHE
WASN'T WHEN SHE WASN'T ACTING
BETTY WHITE DEDICATED HER TIME
TO OUR OTHER LOVE ANIMALS. WHAT
HER LIFE SHE WAS INVOLVED IN
VARIOUS ANIMAL WELFARE
ORGANIZATIONS AND SERVED AS A
COMMISSIONER ON THE LOS ANGELES
THE COMMISSION. SOCIAL JUSTICE
WAS ALSO IMPORTANT TO BETTY
WHITE NOT ONLY WAS SHE AN OPEN
ALLY OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY. SHE
GAVE A PLATFORM TO BLACK TAP
DANCER ARTHUR DUNCAN WHOSE
CAREER WAS LAUNCHED ON THE FIRST
ITERATION OF THE BETTY WHITE
SHOW WITH BACK IN THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES. DESPITE THREATS FROM TV
STATIONS IN THE DEMOCRAT JIM
CROW SOUTH THE BOYCOTT OF HER
SHOW IF SHE DIDN'T FIRE HIM. SHE
VEHEMENTLY REFUSED AND IN FACT
THE SHOW WAS CANCELED SHORTLY
AFTER. IN ADDITION TO EARNING
THE TITLE OF LONGEST TV CAREER
BY A FEMALE ENTERTAINER IN THE
GUINNESS BOOK OF WORLD RECORDS.
SHE WAS AWARDED AN IMPRESSIVE
EIGHT EMMYS IN MULTIPLE
CATEGORIES THREE AMERICAN COMEDY
AWARDS THREE SCREEN ACTORS GUILD
AWARDS AND A GRAMMY. SHE ALSO
HAS A STAR ON THE HOLLYWOOD WALK
OF FAME AND WAS INDUCTED INTO
THE TELEVISION HALL OF FAME IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE AND I'D BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T POINT OUT
THAT SHE WAS HONORED AS THE
EIGHTY FIFTY WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BETTY
WHITE'S BELOVED HUSBAND ALLEN
LUDDEN PRECEDED HER IN DEATH
FORTY YEARS AGO. AND SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER THREE STEP
CHILDREN FROM HER MARRIAGE TO
ALAN. AND THE MILLIONS AROUND
THE WORLD- LAUGHTER I ASKED WITH
GERMAN OR MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM. THIS CARILLO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS TO
CELEBRATE THE LIFE OF THE SENT
THEY FIT IN ON THIS IN TODAY
THAT I MOSTLY GOT ON CHETA. THE
CENTER LOVINGLY KNOWN AS TENT
THEY WAS BORN ON FEBRUARY
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN FORTY. AND
LEFT THIS GOOD EARTH ON DECEMBER
TWELFTH. OF THIS OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. HIS PASSING HAS BEEN
FELT AROUND THE WORLD AS
MILLIONS MOURNED HIS DEATH.
CELEBRATE HIS LIFE HIS MUSIC HIS
ART HIS MOVIES HIS LEGACY. HE
HAS LEFT A VOID IN MY HEART AND
THE HEARTS OF MILLIONS. A NATIVE
OF WHAT I HAD A HIGH SCHOOL MAKE
COOL CHANT IS EMBEDDED INTO THE
FABRIC OF A RICH MEXICAN MEXICAN
AMERICAN CHICANO LATINO CULTURES
AND BEYOND. HIS MUSIC CREATED A
SPACE FOR COMMUNITYTOGETHER AND
COMMEMORATE MONUMENTAL MOMENTS
IN OUR LIVES. AT BAPTISMS
BIRTHDAYS CONTINUED US WEDDINGS
BARBEQUES BREAK UPS AND EVEN
BASEBALL GAMES TENTH IT WAS
EVERYWHERE. HIS MUSIC COULD END
FIGHT AT A BAR AND I KNOW AND
HAVE SEEN PLENTY OF GROWN MEN IN
TEARS WHILE LISTENING AND
SINGING ALONG. TO HIS MUSIC AT
ANTENNA. GENTIS MUSIC WAS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE A PART OF
THE SOUNDTRACK OF OUR LIVES.
COMING FROM HUMBLE BEGINNINGS
TENT THIS PASSION FOR MUSIC
STARTED AS A STREET PERFORMER
PLANE IN THE TOWN PLAZA WHICH
LED HIM TO MEXICO CITY. AND
ULTIMATELY BECOMING A WORLD
RENOWNED ICON. WE SENT THIS
CAREER INCLUDED FIFTY MILLION
ALBUMS SOLD WORLDWIDE FIFTY ONE
OF HIS ALBUMS ARE LISTED BY THE
RECORDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF AMERICA AS A GOLD PLATINUM
AND MULTI PLATINUM SELLING
RECORDS. HE EARNED MANY
ACCOLADES INCLUDING THREE GRAMMY
AWARDS NINE LATIN GRAMMY AWARD
THE STAR ON THE HOLLYWOOD WALK
OF FAME AND SOLD OUT CONCERTS
AROUND THE WORLD. HE WAS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ONE OF THE
BEST SELLING REGIONAL MEXICAN
MUSIC ARTISTS OF ALL TIME. IN
LOS ANGELES MY GOOD FRIEND AND
HIP HOP RADIO PERSONALITY BIG
BOY WORKED WITH TENDED TO BRING
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER BY DRESSING UP THE
CHATTEL AND SINGING ALONG SIDE
TENT THAT SOLD OUT. L. A.
CONCERT. ONE OF HIS SONGS YOUR
THIRTY GUEST CHAPLAIN A BETTER
LEON QUE YO MA'AM WAIT A SEC IT
THEN THE DOES. GIVE YOU A- AND
IN FACT THE WORLD DID CRY.
CHANDON TRANSCENDED RACE HIS
MUSIC TRANSCENDED LANGUAGE WE
SHOULD ALL BE MORE LIKE WE SENT
THE FERNANDES HE LOVED WHAT HE
DID HE LOVE TO ALL OF US HIS
AUDIENCE MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
THE LATINO CAUCUS AND CHANT THE
FANS ACROSS CALIFORNIA I ASKED
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF OUR
BELOVED. BE SENT THEY FED ON
THIS GIVE YOU MUCH AND- THANK
YOU MISS CARILLO. MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES OF THE DESERT
PRINT IN THE JOURNAL REQUEST
RETURN OF MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
MONDAY JANUARY SEVENTEENTH IS A
HOLIDAY DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR DAY. TUESDAY JANUARY
EIGHTEENTH FLOOR SESSION IS AT
ONE PM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING OR
FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
THIS LITTLE MOVES AND MISS
CARILLO SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL TUESDAY
JANUARY EIGHTEENTH. AT ONE PM.
WE ARE EXERT.